Oh
so yes introduction to convolutional
neural networks in this talk I'll
actually be will be in three parts I'll
explore these three questions by
motivating why one would use neural
networks then explore what they really
are and finally I'll end by showing you
how to use Python to Train convolutional
neural networks and if people are
interested I can I'll discuss some ideas
and things to pursue in this area as
well a little bit about myself I work as
a researcher at the Frey University in
the databases group here in Berlin and
I'm also a co-founder of a startup based
in Switzerland and Berlin and we're
actually looking at new ways of doing
shopping and using some of these ideas
there as well okay to get started an
important task in machine learning
actually involves classifying some
labelled data like the properties of
some certain species of flower and if
you're given that and and some name it's
in its name then you can predict what a
particular species is just given just
its features right and for two
properties or features and three types
of labels you can use a simple linear
classifier like the one here and so if
you're given some unknown species you
can just see where it falls in in in
this decision boundary and you can
predict its type we can predict its
label so it's a easy exercise and you
can imagine that this classification was
calculated or obtained by some kind of a
minimization method which found the
optimal decision boundary that by
reducing or minimizing some cost and
this was the computational intensive
part of doing this many real-world
problems on the other hand do not
separate out so nicely into more or less
linear decision boundaries or and one
way to deal with with this is to
introduce nonlinear features like the
square of the sepal length or the square
of the the width and with these
quadratic features you end up with you
end up more or less with the curved
decision boundaries and on the other
hand a lot of interesting problems
especially these these days have a lot
more than a handful of features right so
a problem with say hundred features or
dimensions and if we have cubic if you
have cubic feet features well that's
already 170,000 features now and this
kind of for each new dimension we add it
kind of grows the computation kind of
grows exponentially and so there's a
limit to the to what these methods can
do as we increase their complexity all
right so we very quickly hit hit that
limit and if you consider the problem of
object recognition in images it's a
simple problem for a brain but computers
only see pixels and even for a 32 by 32
pixels we end up with 1,024 pixels and
if it's RGB then it's 3000 features and
so each input to our model is a vector
of length 3000 approximately 3000 right
that's just a 32 by 32 pixel and now if
we say if we want to fit a quadratic
model we end up with around 9 million
features and then at 100 by 100
grayscale image we have around 50
million quadratic features
so classical machine learning approaches
are not a good way to learn such high
dimensional models like emission tech so
perhaps we can use an algorithm that
tries to mimic the brain and in
particular the networks of neural
connections and the theory is that this
is the way the brain works in trying to
in learning complex tasks and there are
a number of results that show that this
is a movie by the way of a working brain
of an organism you can see some of the
some of the neurons activating and parts
of the brain kind of using more oxygen
anyway so I thought that was interesting
and so the main idea of neural networks
is to mimic these connections on a
computer to learn some features and then
for prediction we see if a particular
neuron is activated for some given input
data right so it's a relatively old
oldish idea and kind of become the state
of the art technique these days for
certain problems but they had a bit of a
lull in their popularity in the 90s
around the time this movie was was
released or maybe part three I forget I
even remember my father eventually
changing his PhD from using neural
networks to something else around the
same time and yeah so it wasn't too
popular these days however they're among
the most sophisticated tools being used
by all the big technology giants like
Google with their Google brain project
microsoft also has something called
project Adam I suppose every big search
engine image aggregator has something
similar that they're working on these
days and the reason the main reason for
this resurgence is due to faster
computers and accelerators like graphic
card
as well as bigger better label data's
for frame right this combined with the
recent advances in the field over the
last 10 years kind of mean that we can
potentially use neural networks to learn
very complex features automatically and
relatively quickly on commodity clusters
like like those on Amazon for example so
more or less researchers and more
smaller companies can do something
similar for not so for not for not for
and it's not too expensive and we'll get
back to the GPU computing a bit later
but I first wanted to give you a higher
level overview of how neural networks
work in particular for image detection
type problems and and why they actually
allow this nonlinear learning the
simplest possible neural network you can
think of is just a single neuron didn't
given by this diagram and this one's
called the logistic unit where the
output is the logistic function which
outputs a probability between 0 and 1
given some given some weights
coefficient vector beta the X 0 the X 0
is typically always 1 it's called the
bias unit and it always outputs one and
kind of has its reason we have a reason
for doing that it's extremely simple
model of what a neuron does and in that
it gets a number of inputs and and and
and some output is computed right and in
the neural network lingo this beta is
called is usually referred to as the
weight in terms of the computation we're
doing nothing more than just logistic
classification here given some some
weights all we're doing is just finding
that decision boundary that linear
decision boundary so
it's this is nothing more than just
logistic regression you get a neural
network when you put a bunch of these
neurons together as here again a bit of
more lingo layer one is called input
layer and layer three the last layer is
the output layer and this outputs our
hypothesis our model layer two in
between actually any layer in between
are called hidden layers okay so that's
a very simple model of a of a neural
network and these functions the AI the a
index with the J's are the activation
functions of a particular neuron in a
particular layer so we label the
superscripts are the layers and each of
the unit activation functions are also
numbered one and four now just consider
that logistic function from the last
slide okay so how does it how does this
work well what's happening
computationally is that for each of the
sum for each layer we have some given
matrix of weight which controls the
function mappings from one layer to the
next right and we can compute then for
each input image is is our goes to a
corresponding input unit and then for
each each activation function we just
calculate with the from the sigmoid
function together with these weights the
appropriate output and G is our that
sigmoid function at that logistic
function for example
and then the final output for is given
by some other fixed weight matrix theta
2 and this for some given matrix and
this then returns our final kind of
hypothesis for a given data okay so
computationally that's all that's going
on you just see what what the matrix is
and what it's what it's how we compute
the activation for it and this justice
defines the mapping from our input to
our model given some weight theta and
this is called forward propagation
because we were kind of propagating the
activations forward through through the
network all right just to give you an
idea of how we can use this to learn
complex features now well as an
intuition if we hit layer 1 and we're
just left with layer 2 now this is just
logistic regression and we're just using
the features from layer 2 so layer 3
just computes the normal logistic
function and the weight matrix playing
the role of the parameters and using the
features a1 to a3 in this case right so
the great thing now is that these a1 a2
a3 are actually learned as functions of
the input so some other parameter theta
one in this case is choosing the
parameters to then feed into layer 3
which is doing logistic regressions so
now depending on what this theta 1 is
set to Y are learning why the process of
learning we can learn interesting
features of our data right
so therefore we hope to get a better
estimate than just polynomial
classification because we have now the
flexibility to learn whatever feature we
want in order to get to in order to get
the layer tool which we then feed into
layer 3 alright so that's the main
intuition of why you can learn nonlinear
features and of course we can define our
own network architecture
now layer 2 is computing some complex
feature and layer 3 is taking these
complex features and then computing even
more complex features and so by the time
we get to layer 4 we end up with a very
sophisticated nonlinear model in essence
we can also extend this idea to multiple
multi-class logistic classification to
where for example for the problem of
object recognition we have more than one
category which we are trying to
distinguish between handwriting
detection is another example of
multi-class classification problem and
all we need to do there is we generalize
our output layer to have now multiple
nodes and each output is then then a
vector corresponding to the to the
appropriate output that we want so in
this case we have two classes and so we
have these vector of size two of
probabilities so so that's a way to
extend it and given the weight
parameters it's relatively easy to make
predictions now on new data by a
feed-forward mechanism which I described
before so now the issue is how do you
choose these weight parameters well a
naive thing to do would be to perturb
the weight matrix randomly and then if
it leads to a smaller mean square error
then you stick with that new weight mate
weight matrix and repeat well it's not
really efficient
usually and so we don't do that
another approach you could think of
would be to maybe turn on and off some
activation nodes which is a bit better
but still not computationally optimal so
you turn on on and off some node and if
it improves improves the mean square you
stick with that otherwise you you move
on this is actually a better approach
called back propagation which kind of
back propagates the errors starting from
the output layer so it starts from the
output layer and back propagates the the
errors and it's kind of analogous to
running something like gradient descent
on some cost function of the activation
functions and typically you also have a
penalty for how much you're trying to
minimize something like Ridge regression
type penalties and the idea is that by
having this penalty you make sure that
only the most important features get
learned and this is actually the process
which we call training and I don't want
to talk anymore about back propagation
except that to say to to get started we
need to initialize our weight matrix to
some random values rather than just
having them all zero and and once you do
that I mean back propagation can be done
rather efficiently and so yeah it's just
an exercise in doing that as a recipe
now we have now a whole technique for
training neural networks and this turns
out to be you pick an architecture you
randomly initialize the weights you
implement forward propagation to get
your your model for any input X then you
implement code to compute this cost
function like the residual sum of
squares plus some penalty then you
implement back propagation and to
minimize the cost function for the best
theta the best weight and then you you
train your neural network from with the
training
to find find this best theater and we'll
probably not find a global optimum but
gradient descent actually does quite a
good job in minimizing this cost
function all right so we have our basic
neural network and we can we can train
it now
so for the problem of feature extraction
and images well the thing with images is
that a fully connected network with with
even at 32 by 32 images computationally
quite extensive and one solution is that
each hidden unit is connected to a small
subset of input units but even that
turns out to be quite computationally
intensive you end up with a lot of these
fully connected units and and the thing
about images is that they have this
property which is called which is that
they're kind of stationary meaning
patches of the images kind of repeat
around the images and this suggests that
the features that we learn it at one
patch of the image can be applied to
other patch of the image and so we can
use the same feature this learn feature
in different locations of the image the
thing is if you if you did that for
example if you had four by four patches
sampled randomly over a large image and
apply this you end up again with a huge
number of features once again and it's
it's it's much more efficient it's
better if we would take these 4x4
features and actually convolve them with
the larger image this way we obtain kind
of a classification of those patches
which is a bit smaller dimensional than
the patches themselves at each at each
place we
we're doing this filtering so what is
convolution well it's kind of a
mathematical operation of taking a
filter function which is the size of
your patch and applying it to the image
to get a number or a smaller
representation of that patch all right
doing this for oops doing this for
patches we end up with a layer of
convolved features and after obtaining
features we would next like to use them
these features for classification and in
theory you could use all these extracted
features with the classifier but again
this is too computationally intensive
due to the large number of features but
there's also the risk of now overfitting
the model you end up with so many
features that it works perfectly for
your training data but fails miserably
for any new test data so we need to fix
this
now overfitting issue one thing we can
do is if you remember that we decided to
obtain these convolve features because
it images have this stationary property
which implies that features that are
useful in one region are also likely to
be useful in other regions so to
describe a large large image one could
naturally one natural approaches to
aggregate statistics of these features
at various locations for example one
could compute the mean or max values of
a particular feature over a region of
the image and so you can use these
summary statistics which are much lower
dimension dimensional compared to the
extracted features and they actually
improve the result for learning because
now you have much less overfitting you
have much less features that you're
learning over and these aggregate
operations are
carpooling depending on the type of
statistics
it's either mean pooling or max pooling
and and one can choose the pooling
region to be contiguous areas in the
image and only pool features generated
from the same hidden unit and these
units will be translation invariant
that's another property this means that
the same feature will be active even
when the image undergoes some small
translation and this translation
invariance features is often desirable
in many tasks like object recognition or
even audio recognition alright what did
I want you to say I think now we have
more or less everything to describe a
convolutional neural network which is a
neural network composed of one or more
convolutional layers often with some sub
sampling step and then followed by one
or more fully connected layers and the
architecture of convolutional neural
network is designed to take advantage of
the this 2d structure of an input image
and the 2d input like lichen
can also be like a speech signal for
example and another benefit of these
convolutional neural networks is that
they're easy to train and have much
fewer parameters than those fully
connected neural networks with the same
number of hidden units so by doing these
convolutions you end up with much fewer
parameters so how do we do that in
Python well in Python there are a number
of convolutional neural network
libraries the popular ones are the CUDA
confident or on cognitive
- which was released a few days ago pi
brain is also used and cafes actually
another really nice library you can even
do it yourself with the piano and pi
learn - backends for a lot of the
heavy GPU computations so it's not too
hard to to just do it yourself today I
wanted to look at CUDA confident which
is a fast C++ or CUDA implementation of
these neural networks and you can with
it you can model arbitrary layers of
connectivity and network depth and it
works on NVIDIA GPUs and the main
advantage is that it kind of provides
efficient implementations of
convolutions in for CUDA GPUs and you
can get the you can get the code from
github and this one this library from
Daniel is a particularly nice because it
kind of it's easy to get going with it
and it kind of is a mirror of the
original code so to get started the main
advantage of this github library is that
we use C Meg to build the CUDA bindings
for Python so if you have if your setup
has a recent CUDA CPU a GPU and all the
development environment setup then all
you really need to do is just call C
make on it and more or less you'll be
ready to go to start using it off you
also need map matplotlib and the
appropriate lotta libraries as well so
to begin with let me just discuss the
type of data that we can train on cuda
confident expects data to be stored at
as python pickle objects and the other
thing is that the data must be broken
down into these batches and here i have
a data set consisting of 60,000 32 by 32
color images in
classes with the 6,000 images per class
and the data said is divided into five
training batches and one test batch each
with the 10,000 images in in the Python
pickle format and who the confident
comes with the utilities to to to to
generate from your image data to these
pickle formats and to define the
architecture of your neural network you
must first write a layer definition file
the first thing you need to add to your
layer definition file is a data layer
type data line indicates that this is a
data data layer and our Python data
provider outputs a list of two elements
the actual image and the label for the
image and so the line data index 0
indicates that the layer name data is
mapped to the to the image and similarly
the line data index 1 indicates that
this is the label it maps to the labels
of that image next a convolutional layer
applies a small set of filters as I said
all over these images and you specify
them like this the column one bracket is
the name that we're calling this layer
so we can reference it in other other
layers input equals data says that the
layer will take as input the layer name
data of three channels and we apply 32
filters to this image we then add a
padding of 2 image pixel borders of 0
and a stride of 1 to indicate the
distance between these successive
filters and the convolution filter size
is 5 by 5 with some initial weight in
this layer from a normal distribution
with mean 0 and standard deviation 0.01
right this partial sum parameter is a
kind of a affects the performance of the
gradient computation and it's worth
trying out different values for it as
one
another type of layer is the pooling
layer here it performs local per channel
pooling on its input we use max pooling
rather than average or mean pooling and
the input here you see can comes from
the comp one layer and we use a
rectified linear neuron a type of neuron
we can define other types of neurons
here as well all right a fully connected
layer you is of type FC fully connected
and it's gets its input from some pool
three layer actually we are defining two
layers FC 64 is a fully connected layer
and with 64 64 outputs and the probes is
a softmax that takes that those 6 FC 64
as input and outputs outputs things that
can be interpreted as probabilities and
this type of layer is useful for
actually for classification tasks
finally a your architecture
configuration must define an objective
function to optimize here we're defining
this multinomial logistic regression
objective it's specified like this with
cost log regression it takes two inputs
the two labels and the predicted
probabilities and we define the label we
define the labelled layer or earlier on
and the probability layer we get from
the softmax layer alright so more or
less once you have that done you also
need a parameter file for each of the
layers in this file you can specify your
learning parameters we will that you
want to change during the course of
training the thing is that confident
checkpoints its operation so you can go
back and change these parameters and
restart the computation once you have
something going and
yeah so to get started once we have
these two files and we have the data in
the pickle format we can actually do the
training this will this command will
cause the net to train on the data
located in the data path and save
checkpoints into the safe path folder so
it uses batches you can see it uses
batches one to five uses batches one to
five for training and batch six for
testing and for every 13 training
batches it processes will compute the
test error once and the testing
frequency is also the checkpoint saving
frequency so every 13 a pox
every 13 times we loop over we do a
check one and the output actually tells
you the epoch and the batch number as
well as the values of all of the
objectives that we're optimizing the
cost dot log regression objective
happens to return two values the average
and negative log probability of the data
under the model and the classification
error rate which is the second number
you see that even we did a few epochs
here and we're at 36.7%
classification error this training will
by default continued till 50,000 epochs
by default but you can change that as
well and to see the results or see to
look inside your neural network at any
time you can use the show net script it
plots the training test error over time
and displays you can also use it to
display the filters that the neural
network has learned and also plot the
predictions and errors like I'm doing
here right so as we go more forward our
training error will keep decreasing and
at some point we'll be we will be M we
will start
the tester will start increasing because
of overfitting to view the filters that
we had the the network has learned well
we call this the script with the show
filters and give it the layer the name
of the layer this kind of is
visualization is mostly useful only for
looking at data connected layers the
deeper you go into the into your network
the less interpretable these outputs
become and if if your output has three
channels it merges it into a RGB file
but doesn't mean these colors don't mean
anything to actually do some predictions
on some test data you can run the show
net script with the show pro show with
the show predictions probabilities
this shows eight random images from the
test batch there are two labels and the
four labels considered most probable by
the model the true labels probability is
shown in red and you can see here did
quite well only one image was
misclassified as a frog rather than a
dog so not so bad these neural networks
actually suffer a lot from from
overfitting so let me just briefly talk
about regularization which is the this
idea of of only choosing the features
that are the most important one way of
regularization is called dropout
introduced by Hinton and when training
with dropout are randomly selected the
subset of activations are set to zero
within each layer and the reason for
this is that kind of outside the scope
here but it prevents complex code
options in
which a feature detector is only helpful
in the context of several other feature
detectors by doing drop out each neuron
kind of learns a detective feature that
is generally helpful for producing the
correct answer given the internal
context in which it must operate so it
kind of is the most important you can
select the most important ones another
recent technique is called drop connect
which instead sets a randomly selected
subset of weights within the network to
zero so CUDA complement also implements
these I think drop connectors in a
separate branch and hasn't been merge
yet but yeah you can play around with
these two techniques as well and a
number of cattle competitions have
actually been won using convolutional
neural networks this one to classify
galaxies needed for convolutional layers
and three fully connected layers and
it's actually finished first and this
blog post kind of goes into a lot of
detail into what what the author did to
do to win the challenge
also for speech recognition
convolutional neural networks work quite
well let me finish up by talking a bit
about the issues of paralyzing
convolutional neural networks typically
we train these networks over big data
sets it's not obvious how to actually
parallel parallel eyes this training
multi-gpu seems one approach it's
paralyzing them over a cluster is
another approach but there's actually no
standard framework for doing this
large-scale learning like there is for
Hadoop like there is for MapReduce with
Hadoop or streaming computation with
spark or stock or storm so there is
something missing in this in this area
so one way to paralyze your network is
across the model dimension so different
workers train different part of the
model
or across the data where different
workers train on different data examples
each has its own drawbacks and benefits
actually in practice what people find
and this data parallelism appears to be
attractive for convolutional layers
where which contains about 90% of the
computation and about 5% of the
parameters while model parallelism
appears attractive for fully connected
layers which constitutes about five to
ten percent of the total computation and
most of the parameters are here so
there's a kind of a change in regime of
how you paralyze things and it can get
quite complicated in terms of improving
your training times the algorithms also
need to be designed to take advantage of
the architecture in particular the GPUs
and multi multi-core CPUs and the main
difficulty here is if you look at this
architecture of a newish system with the
with the CPU and the GPU the main
problem is transferring data through
these bottlenecks the PCI bus as well as
the network so this is the fastest you
can get at these days but this is where
the main bottleneck is as you transfer
memory from your host to your device for
the GPU to work on it this is quite fast
so all these are in kind of in scale all
right and the trick here is to kind of
hide latency of these transfers by doing
computation in parallel to the transfers
so that the GPU multi processors are
kept busy and are not left waiting for
some data to arrive and this is a hard
especially when you have multiple GPUs
in the server and the new CUDA confident
too is written with this kind of
philosophy in mind to to optimize it for
multi GPUs so if you want to explore
that have a look at
- alright so I think hopefully you get
an idea of the general general method
the techniques of using convolutional
neural networks and I encourage you to
go and try out these libraries and
perhaps with some sample data or your
own data and explore new ideas and I'll
stop here for any questions or or
feedback thank you any questions yeah
thank you for the interesting talk how
do you define or determine the number of
layers and neurons that make sense most
for a given situation yes yeah I think
so you have to have to play around with
with how much features get detected with
training and test datasets and so
typically you would have three or four
convolutional layers and typically you
would have things in which are multiples
of two multiples of 2 and so 64 so
things that divide up nicely and are
easily cash so you need to try to try it
out I would say thank you yeah so that's
another thing lacking with the neural
networks is that it's hard to interpret
what's actually going on and that's
another active area of research
thank you recently Google and Facebook
have shown some some success with new
networks and especially deep face from
Facebook can you give us some insight if
you have how they parallelized
there yeah so most probably they have
they have kind of a framework for doing
for doing this for for doing this kind
of parallelism kind of easier kind of
libraries internal libraries and
frameworks api is for doing that this is
currently missing in the open source
space so it's a it's a request for
perhaps Python can be the go-to
framework for such a system so most
probably they have kind of these
parameter servers and I think Jeff Dean
talked about it as well kind of the
challenges and as a complement to that
there was a blog post some time ago by
Netflix who explained how they scaled
continents to the cloud and that's
actually tied to some talks we had on
hyper parameter optimization there are
many hyperparameters so what you can do
is have an Amazon GPU instance for every
point in your grid search so for every
possible hyper parameter and that's why
you don't need to paralyze at the
component level you just try many many
components and in practice what works
the best is any way to mix the
predictions of multiple continents so
that's a way to scale up okay hmm okay
thank God I thank you thanks
you
you